[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
very excited to be talking about
synthetic biology we have dr. Richie
Coleman joining us on the show hello
hello thank you so much for coming on
thank you really excited really excited
it was because we were at the church lab
in Cambridge in over January
interviewing George church that we ended
up getting in touch that's right now
here you are on the show and Richie's
background is awesome he is a senior
research scientist and lead of the
synthetic biology platform at the VESA
Institute for biologically inspired
engineering at Harvard University he
oversees all research conducted by the
synthetic biology platform including
advances in nucleic acid synthesis and
sequencing neuro tech gene therapy aging
reversal of gene editing organism
recoding Institute omics organ
engineering stem cell therapy extinct
species resurrection and all aspects
relating to the intersection of
synthetic biology and synthetic
chemistry Ricci is also kopi I along
with George church at the Department of
Genetics at Harvard Medical School of an
IEEE ARPA funded project to map synaptic
connectivity in large brain volumes and
you can find the links below to Richie
Coleman comm as well as the VESA
Institute page his LinkedIn profile and
his Google Scholar page all right Richie
let's start things off with one of our
favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts in the direction
of our world yeah so I think from a
scientific perspective it's a pretty
exciting time to be round right I mean
science just keep progressing the
technology keeps getting better and
better if you think about the CRISPR
craze which I'm sure we'll get to it a
little bit that didn't exist five six to
ten years ago right that's a relatively
new technology and so what can happen in
five ten years from now it's kind of an
unimaginable thing it could
exponentially increase and get very
exciting and most certainly will be
exciting
but on the flip side if you think about
you know in terms of the United States
and the world maybe politically it's
kind of a scary time I think in humanity
especially as a scientist when you think
about kind of the post fact argument
lists dynamic going on that's that's
kind of quite scary so we'll see how
this trend continues you know yeah the
fact that we haven't had some of the
cutting-edge technologies even just a
couple years ago and now those are kind
of opening up the edge of knowledge for
us for people to go and dig and see
whatever they can discover with these
new tools that are being me that's huge
but then also like you said there's a
lot of geopolitical things that we have
to get through Ritchie let's hear about
you from your journey where were you
born I was born in the suburbs of
Chicago okay so yeah kind of about 30
minutes outside the city and how did you
get hooked growing up in Chicago how did
you get hooked into synthetic biology
what had your interest in science form
it's just something that was always
there I was always a technical person I
always was interested in science and all
of my classes and things like that so
there's no question my mind that I was
gonna do something of that nature I mean
maybe something like architecture
engineering but that was pretty much
kind of always a thing we ended up going
to be Seema Science and Industry all a
time becomes like a second home I don't
know if we went there more because I was
interested in it or became I was
interested in because we went there more
but I remember that is a good childhood
memory and then how about then venturing
into all the way into like Santa Clara
University where you did your BS in
chemistry all the way up to the U of
Illinois you went back that's right
so for me it just ended up being at that
time a question of what kind of science
I was gonna do and I gravitated towards
chemistry because I think it seemed like
a happy medium between the highly
mathematical physics and the more sort
of fact memorization based biology I
kind of like both and so when for the
chemistry route then went to graduate
school because I liked organic chemistry
because it was the one field subfield
that popped out that had some sort of
that is amiss like a tool very applied
and so I went into graduate school with
that mindset saying like I'm gonna be a
synthetic chemist and then what were
your like big aha moments during the the
bachelors and during the PhD where you
were just like oh my gosh this is
exploding my mind yeah I had a big
transition really early and in graduate
school where I think I was just I had
committed somewhat earlier to that that
subfield and I went to a small undergrad
in of a graduate program so I wasn't
really aware of all the kind of science
that was going on at the time and what
ended up happening was Francis Crick the
famous scientist died early
two-thousands and it was big news I was
reading the obituaries and of course I
knew him as the co-discoverer of the
structure of DNA like most people know
him for but then I was reading about
what he had done for like the last
thirty years of his life and I found out
he was a prominent research scientist in
the field of consciousness and at that
time I I think I didn't even know that
people studied that sort of thing it
didn't seem like a scientific pursuit
and so it really just kind of flipped a
switch and it opened up a door and I as
a sub hobby I almost became interested
in I definitely became interested in
neuroscience it was a completely as a
career path at the time and so be this
thing where I would get really
interested and I would read up on and I
try and cram the two worlds together and
I couldn't find a way to do it and I
kind of get to press and drop it and
then go back to what I have to do and
then something else would happen I'd go
back and this is this is a series of
things that happen throughout graduate
school you know the consciousness stuff
is like a really basic kind of
philosophical science questions and the
science questions own philosophical but
like big questions in the universe and
then I remember seeing a lot of stuff on
the brain computer interfaces it was a
cover of nature with this electrode
array of this paralyzed person
controlling things on the screen and
once again I remember looking at that
and then looking at what I was doing and
I was like I much rather be doing this
wasn't distill stuff over here
and so I'm trying to think of some way
to make the paths kind of converge and
again didn't happen so I'd have to kind
of scrap it
and then there was a third moment when I
found out about this technique called
optogenetics yes right where you you'd
be able to essentially stimulate the
brain cells with light so it's a
combination of genetic techniques with
hardware right so use a virus or a
variety of genetic techniques to put
these ion channels that basically move
ions across a gradient with pulses of
colored light which is what turns in
what's what cells do when the fire
action potentials so you can use all
this genetic trickery to put these
things in very specific places in the
brain and then just pulse it with light
and get this amazing control and I think
that was kind of the straw that broke
the camel's back and I said well listen
I'm just not gonna do this stuff anymore
I'm gonna go and do this stuff and so I
decided to make like a pretty big switch
because it was a parent I couldn't I
couldn't really bring the two worlds
together
I've kind of making a successful
trajectory into like biomaterials tissue
engineering things that I would I found
interesting but I think I made a list in
my head of you know my priorities and IP
of this realization they're like I'm not
really gonna settle for like the 15th
thing on the list I'm pretty much gonna
you know do the first thing on the list
those looks I felt relatively young at
the time I said I have a lot of time to
go so I'm just gonna go for it and was
fortunate enough to have somebody hire
me in a lab to do that sort of stuff
even though I had zero experience with
it so it worked out again these
reoccurring themes that happen from
people that we sit down with that we get
the young museums that influence young
kids that get into science and then the
also the you wanted something that was
translational you want something that
had like almost immediate impact yeah I
mean I think that's why a lot of people
gravitate towards the brain sciences I
think that's why there's you know the
brain initiative why well just brains
should be sort of in a related context
is that there's horrific brain diseases
that don't have a cure and all this is
because of this massive complexity of
the brain it's because it's so complex
it operates and then you have your
emerging emergent property of viewer
experiences which is kind of the most
amazing thing right I mean that's you
know everything that you are doing or
experiencing has some sort of material
manifestation that goes on which in
itself is kind of crazy but then do you
think of the opposite
you can actually come from an external
you manipulate it and presumably that's
going to change your experience yeah
right so I mean there's magnetic
stimulation and things like that and
then there's these patients with deep
brain stimulators and you can read
things in the literature of them putting
being put in the wrong place and turning
them on and kind of bizarre effects
happening yeah the fact that we can not
only that that we feel consciousness
from what is emerging from within our
body but then also that we can stimulate
transcranial yeah and have mented
experience Wow
yeah yeah and you have the whole history
of like traumatic brain disease and
injuries and all these very bizarre
neuropsychiatric disorders to look at
right so people get a car accident none
of those weird stuff just seems to
happen yeah right you wake up you have
this cohesive experience of the world
and you're like alright then what you
know it's just this one solid thing
that's happening and then something
happens to somebody there's like a
fragment that that's offset and you're
like I guess it's really just a million
pieces working in concert how is that
even work it's kind of amazing and even
the fact that I guess consciousness
exists right that's kind of the amazing
thing why does a series of things happen
that creates them to be aware you know
lots of things are complicated with the
TV's complicated right you know the this
building's complicated a lot of
biology's complicate but something about
the brains specifically the human brain
where it's just connected somehow and
then it just it operates and then you
have human experience yeah and really I
mean all society is is the result of
like this this these objects operating
with some sort of agenda and then you
can look at like the the history of the
universe and then like humanity comes up
and now you have this these agents and
like chaos ensues the universe from the
emergence of human brains is amazing is
it true that we don't know what 70% of
the the brain does still I mean a matter
well no I don't they used to say that
you only use 20% of your brain which is
which is true and that you only use 20
brain at a given time so I think at that
that got kind of coerced into like a pop
pop culture idea that there's like this
vacancy of like dark matter I don't
think it's quite like that I mean it's
kind of crude scale mapped out you know
people know what these things do
crudely but cohesive theory of the of
the brain does not yet exist thank you
now okay so when when you were finding
yourself doing this like transition
chemistry with neuroscience was this
kind of some of the work that you're
doing with the postdoc at BU as well as
Harvard Medical School the MIT Media Lab
yes - tell us a little bit about that
yeah so my postdoc was in the the neuro
field so I got in the lab that did this
optogenetics technique and so from my
postdoc it was almost all Mouse work so
I went from organic synthesis in a hood
to like brain surgery and mice and so I
had I had a couple of different projects
one was a drug delivery to the brain
which is a huge problem right things
don't get in you want to deliver a drug
there's all these barriers so I worked
with a surgeon Harvard Medical School to
develop a ghost's surgical technique for
that and then we also had some like nano
material delivery agents that we did
with that and so my time in my
affiliation with MIT is also in that so
the lab that co-invented the
optogenetics technique that was I was
working with okay yeah an optimum Jetix
for neuromodulation is beautiful and I
think it has a lot of potential for our
augmentation it's a very exciting field
yeah
so then what about then you kind of got
into biomaterials engineering a couple
even like almost four years ago yeah
yeah I mean I'm still sort of thing
about chemistry despite the fact that I
haven't really fully left it it's a
really really useful tool to bring into
biology right so if you can if you can
synthesize molecule synthesize materials
and polymers you can apply that to just
a tremendous amount of biological
questions yes so that always seems to
work its way in because it just ends up
being effective so it's never it's never
gone I think it's a good foundation to
have people start off a chemistry moving
to by
so chemistry enabled you to synthesize
the materials that can then do things
like expand tissues to make it easier to
imagine yep exactly
yeah so there's a technique called
expansion microscopy which we do a lot
of and that's really just a lot of
polymer chemistry you know there's a lot
of chemistry in there and so it just was
amazing how it was one of these things
that kind of just found itself into the
mix in terms of a a tool that translated
yeah that's okay and then give us a
maybe a couple more examples and this
will probably end up wandering us now
into the V substitute because this is
one of the things that this also is
doing is making the these these
synthesizing through chemistry that what
this of these things like polymers that
enable expansion across that to happen
so so then now it's been almost three
years yeah yeah at the Peace Institute
right at the visa Institute and this is
a big deal because V substitute is
biologically inspired engineering and we
have the the first the the first asset
that lists all of the all of the
different things yeah yeah and then gene
delivery genome editing cell engineering
protein engineering nucleic acid
synthesis nucleic acid sequencing I mean
when this is just yeah this is just the
synthetic biology platform so the
vCenter is broken up into platforms yes
right that are associated with some
faculty it's a really unique and
exciting place because it's just at
least the yeah the the the platform and
the whole Institute is supposed to
situate itself in between academia and
industry so it's supposed to take all
the cool technology and then kind of
transition it out into companies or
licensing deals so instead of things
just kind of circulating in this
academic space they're supposed to move
them out in the world I love that right
so it's a very applied place and so
another thing that they have is is
full-time research scientists that are
tasked to do this which is one of the
things as part of the the system that
I'm in sorry I'm like because you just
operate in a different different way
than if you're like a graduate student a
postdoc and academia
or even like a scientist in industry so
it's it's I always say it's kind of the
best of both worlds right because the
the stereotypes of the good stereotypes
of academia is that it's like novel
exciting things right you bring to life
things that never existed before you
just pursue your ideas negative
stereotype is that it's just a bunch of
sort of irrelevant things that you can't
communicate to the world and then
industry of course has scalability right
you can make these huge companies with
tons of people and you crank out
products but at least if you can you can
get the feeling like you're a cog in the
wheel and you're just like part of this
massive team and and companies don't
have is especially big companies don't
have the ability to kind of move quickly
because they're the big so here we can
spend some time we can try and
troubleshoot these crazy ideas and I
think the best part is that we can take
a huge amount of risk so it's ok if we
come up with an idea for something crazy
spend three years it's just bombs I mean
you'd rather it not but your careers not
over you just say ok well let's let's
try and push something else out through
so that's the appeal if you're grad
student postdoc you really have this
this timeframe right where you have to
like I got five years or whatever I
gotta get a couple papers okay to get
out the door we don't have that pressure
we say like we can just focus on getting
this stuff to work let's let's just do
that so it almost is almost as though
these Institute and other of they're
kind of like the scientific Institute's
that are able to run all the
permutations of what could be successful
science that is then applied in industry
and then to be able to have that
actually moverá spilled a more cohesive
I think relationship between academia
and industry and also industry can kind
of go off on its own with the products
without talking to scientists too much
as they iterate it gets like a scape
velocity a minute it they aren't gonna
go but if you're a big company you know
obviously probably going to invest in
basic research but you shouldn't
shouldn't be your main thing you know
you you're probably are gonna want to
spend a very small time and effort
pursuing really crazy things where we
should be spending almost all our time
since doing really crazy
they yeah that's cool so then synthetic
biology platform is one of the platforms
that's right obvious what are the other
platforms there's a soft robotics one
there's a diagnostic chips like
lab-on-a-chip one cool applied materials
I don't remember all the names you know
yeah my allegiance
[Laughter]
so chips robotics I mean your this
venturous these ventures into other yeah
yeah cool cool so alright within within
synthetic biology maybe teach us about
like this idea of biologically inspired
engineering with the effect biology
yeah wonder astound sure sure I mean the
all the platforms have had an
engineering component involved III
always just imagine that as just having
a very applied focus but there's also I
mean there generally are a lot of
Engineers a lot of people that do
hardware development a lot of micro
fluidics a lot of things like that
because again we're aiming to build some
something that can scale and do a lot of
these tasks so synthetic biology broad
what we do is huge I mean this list is
is pretty big if you talk about
synthesis and sequencing at least it's
kind of the backbone of a lot of
industries right so DNA what what bio
lab isn't doing or utilizing something
relating to DNA so there's a current
market for DNA synthesis it's done
chemically a lot of industries do that
and that that has a limit in terms of
the length you can make so we're trying
to push that limit right so if you go
and order an ala go it's generally about
200 base pairs long so you can wear that
and you have to do other ways to kind of
get longer so we're trying to do it
biologically not chemically so you'd be
able to get you know ten times that
that's one of the goals sequencing is
one of the most you know successful
technologies to come out of
biotechnology ever we're still trying to
push that the main the main thrust that
we've done is actually in C in C to
sequence a so less effort towards what
you classically think of is like a box
on a bench that does sequencing and more
of like analyzing
biological tissues and reading on
sequences in their gene delivery and
genome editing and genome editing with
the CRISPR Revolution is something that
we do a lot of and the delivery aspect
this is basically getting the proteins
and nucleic acid there to do what it's
supposed to do so if it's a therapy if
you're gonna do anything in humans you
have to deliver it so that's a lot of
viral engineering suppose so
um out of the let's start with the gene
editing yet one okay so this is you've
mentioned this a very beginning just
that such a just even a you know a
couple years ago this this wasn't even
roaring to the same degree that it is
now right yeah and then now it seems
like we want to have genetic
enhancements we want to eradicate
diseases that these are potentially some
of the most important things especially
when we have our children that we could
prevent
ailments from developing these are very
important technologies right yeah and
it's really just the ease of use of the
tool that's what a come down to so there
used to be a variety of iterations of
this genome editing technology that had
been around for a while the promises are
just really hard to use so there was
these zinc finger nucleases talons the
the crux of a lot of this technology is
that you need to put you need to cut DNA
in very specific places and then control
how it gets repaired so it's a lot of
the genome editing so there used to you
used to be able to well you still can
but the previous iterations involve
protein engineering so you'd have some
sequence that you'd want to target and
then you have to design the proteins
that would recognize that and that's a
protein engineering task and it takes
time and then assumes cast 9 was
invented or I guess discovered that was
just a total game changer because now
it's a it's a RNA DNA recognition event
so you really just have to design the
the complement of the target that you
want with this RNA which is easy because
you know the sequence they just program
the sequence and then the enzyme just
goes there and makes the cuts so as soon
as that happened it was like the volcano
erupting right yeah and so the V
sensitive was one of the first labs to
do the demonstration and you care
so it was like a the initial invention
was was discovered like in a tube and
then there was like kind of a tie for
this demo and we were we were one of
those labs yeah and to have that part of
be a part of the revolution where you
actually get to see it move become so
much easier to make the edits is what's
next what else within the multi-billion
year evolutionary process that we have
yet to discover that we are basically
take and yeah apply to to our desire to
bioengineer our future yeah yeah there's
so much yeah I think the the the way
we're going with it is we're trying to
refine the tools so we can multiplex it
basically so if you have a cell and you
wanna make a cut somewhere you can do
that there's some off-target effects
people are addressing that but we want
to make like let's say a thousand edits
or something all right they can't do
that right now so it's really trying to
push the tools that you can do that so
if you have a if you have a cell you
could presumably engineer it so you
change the code so it's completely
invulnerable to like viral infections
then you have completely like virally
impervious cell lines that you can use
and those that as industry applications
because it's not gonna get wiped out and
I'll lose a million dollars from all the
hit you take you know and then why would
we could we be potentially doing this at
the stage of inception of the of the
child that way we don't even need to be
in injecting with all of the vaccines
down the line could we be making the
child immune to the smallpox and measles
at the yeah I mean that that I mean
there's a whole field of vaccines which
is you know exciting and trying to do
that you can also edit earlier and
earlier that's like a super hot-button
issue right now there's a recent issue
in China very controversial so
everybody's very up in arms about doing
it a kind of like germline editing but
presumably if you have why is that
controversial because you pass you know
if you edit your germline you pass on
everything that you do to future
generations
and especially if you do it you know
you're making changes for the future of
somebody doesn't have a choice in the
matter
hmm but if it's to prevent suffering
right I mean there are instances I mean
there's a whole there's a slew of
genetic disorders that are well
characterized that are very genetically
deterministic so if you have this then
you're going to get this disease I mean
most things don't fall into that
category but there are some and so this
is presumably a way to correct that
mm-hmm I think some opponents would say
you can just screen that out right so
you can have you sort of create several
embryos sequence them and then just pick
the other ones pick the ones that don't
have that don't that genotype
yeah well the proponents of doing the
editing would say that you're creating
more embryos if you consider that a
precious thing yeah you're now creating
more embryos that you're not going to
take onto something yeah and then
there's a slippery slope argument about
the designer babies that people are very
worried about mm-hmm
I don't think there's anything the
current state of the field certainly
cannot do this huge editing I don't
think we understand genetics enough to
even be able to do that and we don't
have the tools to even be able to make
those kinds of engineering tasks but
that's what a lot of people are saying
right now and then you know all of out
of everything that we're gonna even
continue discussing I just want to let
people know that this is just such a
small fraction of what really is what is
what you're doing and what you're yeah
because if you go look at Richie's
Google Scholar page I mean there's so
many publications on there and so to
actually be able to dig into the weeds
of that science people can probably just
reach out to you if they yeah deeper
into the weeds of the science then we'll
try to do our best throughout the
conversation but there's so many things
that these apply to you brought up the
nucleic acid synthesis and sequencing so
sequencing technologies this Carlson
curve that we've been following has just
been incredible that now it's down to
less than a thousand bucks to do a whole
genome sequencing from
to tens of hundreds millions of dollars
and saying so but then the synthesis
part I want to just quickly touch on so
what were you speaking about earlier
when you were saying you were
synthesizing nucleic acids yeah yeah so
DNA and RNA if you there's a lot of
vendors if you need to order a short
sequence of DNA you just put it you know
you felt the form and order and they
send it in the mail and they sent you a
synthesis of nucleic acids right yeah
love to
usually stride maybe a milligram at most
a milligram of dried DNA or RNA that's
right and in just this can be [ __ ]
me ordered from the internet just from a
company and yeah yeah and it's it's it's
made completely synthetically made
synthetic right which is the I think
it's kind of a cool thing I think
there's maybe an intrinsic concept of
vitalism like if it's a a biological
molecule it has some sort of maybe
biological essence to it but it's not
really true if you look at DNA it's a
molecule like anything else and if you
make it in an in a non biological
fashion and you look at the two side by
side they're indistinguishable operator
indistinguishable so if you if you look
at the DNA synthesis it's it's
established chemistry it's been around
for decades now and the precursors are
similar but they're all kind of
optimized in a way to make the organic
chemistry of it work but the the output
comes off the instrument is still the
exact same thing it's just a piece of
DNA but it has limits synthetically like
you know think of your cells replicating
is you have all this DNA replication
machinery making millions and millions
of base pairs of DNA and then if you go
to the current holla go synthesis
technologies like 200 right so it can't
you can't make long sequences
effectively or I guess the the yield
drops right so it's as you get longer
and longer all the imperfections build
up and you kind of get kind of get crap
so there's there's alternate methods to
kind of combine these things and make
longer ones but that initial part still
has that limit so we're trying to break
that limit and what and what is a
nucleic acid made of when you make it
synthetically
what material do oh it's the precursors
are still the monomers it's just the
ends are kind of optimized to fit the
organic chemistry monomers right there
so you have four bases in DNA ATC and G
the bases are still there they're still
attached to a sugar and then you have
that phosphate right and so they said
the two ends that are gonna polymerize
huh and you just have chemical groups on
each end that are going to fit the
chemistry okay so we'll just at one on
top with another in an iterative way and
then you could do with some you know
final ways to kind of knock the
protecting groups off the areas you want
and oxidize the things to get the
backbone the phosphate the right way and
then you just cleave it off and then you
have your L ago I said literally submit
a sequence that I want synthetically
created and that's right Wow Wow
yeah holy cow okay so then um but it so
in situ Bo mix so you're doing
sequencing and what are the cells here
and how are you sequencing them yeah so
this is this video or the still which
I'll have the video up now this is our
technology called v seeker fluorescence
in situ sequencing and so
next-generation sequencing is very
commonplace most of the techniques
actually are imaging techniques you
don't really know because it's kind of
what's under the hood of the instrument
and most people don't care right yeah
people want to sequence something the
using answer mean it gives them the data
and they're not particularly interested
in what's going on in the machine but we
are because we're kind of cracking this
thing open and and trying to force it to
happen on biological samples okay so
what's happening and a lot of these
sequence sequencers are that you're
you're basically getting clusters of the
DNA or RNA or DNA that was once RNA that
you care about and it's doing this
iterative chemistry to make them light
up and change colors the colors tell you
what the base is right and so we're
doing the same thing just inside the
cell so if you look this is a cell this
is all the RNA what was once the RNA
each one of those spots represents an
RNA molecule can we pause it wrong yeah
still alright yeah we can loop it let's
loop it yes okay I'm just to give an
idea of size what is this size here that
were just you know this is about 20
micro micrometers right 20 microns Wow
okay and that's a millionth billionth of
a do a twenty thousand nanometers and
nanometers of bill yes see yeah it's a
power 10 off of a micron so you tell me
oh yeah two orders of magnitude off from
you know millimeter scale often oh yeah
typical this is a relatively standard
cell culture size so and this is
multiple cells this yeah each one of
these with this bright spot represents
the the nucleus and what's what cell is
this these I believe are hex cells
Thanks yeah so heck which is a hair into
figlio kidney cells human epithelial
kidding creamy sauce okay and I think
these these were chosen they it we could
do it a lot of different selves I think
these were chosen because maybe they're
fiber less just a easy to easy to
culture cell for demo purposes I should
the the next slides have have the actual
brain stuff but for here yes what you
want to look at is the little spot right
so that was once an RNA molecule we do a
bunch of chemistry to it you know let's
go back quick just so we can sort of
this what Bo still is easier yeah should
the fluorescence in the cell yeah
they'll go back so it's not anime
oh so it's not animating okay Oh God the
still thought is this still like okay
yeah yeah yeah so each one of these dots
is the RNA is the RNA yeah there's that
much RNA there's actually a lot more
than that there's a lot more than that
but that is sort of a sub sampling of it
an orange and pink and green are
different are nares are just different
fluorescence different bases different
bases all right so we want to know the
bases eat there's four colors four bases
and so we apply the chemistry and it
lights up a certain color I don't know
if hand remember the colors but let's
just say magenta is a so you you'll see
the magenta you'll see a spotty locate
that that position is an A and green
might be a G okay green is G and then
you'll iterate and this button they'll
change colors and that's telling you
literally the sequence of what what that
that is that's actually what's happening
in a sequencer on the bench top or at
least a lot of them but it's happening
in like a glass below cell in a very
controlled environment so we're adopting
what's happening there on to the actual
cell itself on to the cell culture or
the biological sample we can do it in
slices or sample we do in brain slices
cell culture so you can apply what did
you cut week in institute omics or
sequencing and that's right in your
floor these are how are you getting them
to fluoresce like that there's some
chemistry where you basically you'll
have an unknown this stretch of an
unknown you put a primer there's a
couple different ways to do it but I'll
go over them a be the most
straightforward way then you were primer
and you have a polymerase the plumbers
will just fill in it'll just typically
it'll just like take and we'll put the
complement of what's there but we have a
special phosphates the ATC's and G's
that get polymerized in there's special
ones that are labeled with each of these
colors and they also have a blocking
group that means it doesn't just keep
going it puts only one in it stops so
it'll try to pull em out it goes extends
one it stops snap a picture and then you
cut off the floor for and a blocking
group and you just repeat so keep going
one by one and you just read off what's
there
and get the color change and this is a
moment-to-moment change of color that
you're reading through imaging it that's
right and then you can then say that
because it was green then it was pink
than it was orange yeah and you're
reading what that what the RNA exactly
yeah you got the sequence you're
sequencing yeah moment to moment you can
capture the images that fast well you
know this is a there's there's some
fluidic steps imagers fluids right right
so you've run the array action and then
you kind of wash everything out snap a
picture and then you have to run the
other reactions and wash everything out
and so you iterate and then you get you
do the image analysis you can make a
pretty video whoa
and and so then so then every single one
is is every single one of the bits
better they're of RNA are different
they're different transcriptions of RNA
it's possible to have two the same RNA
yeah you know the sequencing it all
comes out of the sequencing yeah it's
unlikely as you can tell just in the
picture that most of them are gonna be
different but you can you can analyze it
and compare it to the non spatial
version and get that data and then you'd
be able to sequence in the cell culture
instead of in the sequencer the
importance of that
yes so I mean you when you do with
without doing it this way you throw away
all spatial information spatial
information so if you had I don't know
tumor biopsy yeah if you want to get the
the transcriptomic or the RNA profile
you'd have to just grind it up and then
put it in one of those instrument you
just have this this list that comes out
you don't actually know where it came
from
yeah so you could detect something
abnormal you wouldn't know if that's
half the cells or one cell and even if
you did you wouldn't know what the
spatial relationship is mmm in biology
it's all spatial relationships with
within complex tissues yes
so this technique allows you just retain
that and find out where it is exactly
cool so you can actually see the spatial
relationships yeah moment moment cool
rather than just getting a list of the
sequence when you grind it up writing
sequences and so in this this example
here we're capturing the endogenous
signals right so that's Darney that's
just actually there but we can do tricks
to label things with DNA just so we can
read out in this fashion right so you
know microscopy is very powerful tool
but you're kind of limited by colors
it's hard to it's hard to look at more
than like four or five things but if
each thing has a sequence associated
with it then you're basically looking at
four to the N number of things where n
is the length okay right so if you have
like 50 things you want to look at and
you could kind of barcode them each with
a sequence then you just have to do a
couple of rounds of this and then you
can see everything right so it allows
this huge multiplexing capacity and
that's really the crux of the the neural
project that I couldn't like at all
yeah let's do that let's dive into the
neural project so this is the brain
initiative massive synaptic connectivity
and large brain volumes it's a super
interesting yeah so you know as I as
everybody knows the brain is just
immensely complex and the connectivity
is really really complicated
each neuron in the cortex at least which
is you know this is a mouse brain by the
way mm-hmm
connects to about like 8,000 others
other Sinnott or other cells yeah
and there's millions and millions of
cells so the connectivity is is
extremely complicated very hard to
figure that out and synapses are are
tiny alright so time I like ten
nanometer scale and then you have macro
scale objects of being the brain so how
do you actually dissect that out how you
figure out and map all these connections
I say the current way of doing it is
just to cut the brain into really really
thin sections stain it and look at
everything but that's like a huge brute
force technique yeah that you can
imagine having some scaling problems
right so we're trying to find new
technology to overcome those scaling
issues so what we're doing is we're bar
coding the cells and in the synapses and
then reading those out so instead of you
know if the cells can be thought of as
roads instead of tracing all the roads
we're just inserting signposts where
they intersect and then reading those
out and from there we can make a Rican
we can make a reconstruction about where
everything crosses not a perfect analogy
but it kind of yeah kind of gets the
point so we do the writing of the the
barcodes with a virus so this is a mouse
brain slice that had a viral injection
who makes the cells green and hence the
cells but each one of these cells
actually now has a barcode like AI
molecular identifier and it's a up
actually it's exactly 30 long so each
one has a different one so within this
context we can identify four to the 30
different cells which is way more in
cells that are in that whole entire
brain probably it's like way more than
the number of sand and the under planet
grains of sand so it's like some
astronomical number so the scaling issue
is kind of completely taken care of by
that right and then we simply have to
read the beds of them back out and
establish the connectivity where the
adjacent ones are that makes sense it's
always a complicated project to explain
it is yeah it is okay so you're
injecting the virus in order for them to
fluoresce in order to give them that
molecular identity to give them a
litigate a molecular identity right so
you know you think about if you just you
if you do colors again you know these
are all green so you say well I want to
find out this
verse pass I'll just make them a
different color you're gonna hit five
right five colors
which is not gonna get you very far far
on the phone okay so I need to give this
sort of a the same kind of thing at an
identifier isn't color
there's just something else that I
really like a barcode yes so I give that
a nucleic acid identifier okay and then
I use our sequencing technology to tell
me what that cell is so they sell number
3,000 and too young its sequence okay oh
you see you can not only uniquely
identify the cells in the brain but then
you can also sequence them individually
that's right and I don't even have to
know so if I you know if I inject my
sequence right here and up here and I
see a spot that give me a sequence here
and here I know it's the same cell right
so I don't have to sit there and trace
this path you might care less about that
so you can do long range in addition to
short range and then and then do you
follow that same protocol of the
Instituto mix where you're yeah where
you're fluorescing them yep yeah we do
the same the same technique as on those
cells and that's how you sequence them
after that you've identified given them
the identifier x' yeah so if you go to
the next slide okay cool that's what
this picture will be so this is a static
image of one of the imaging cycles so
the preview changes colors yeah this
one's not changing colors it's just
thick so it's as virtuous as if you're
scanning through okay you can see each
one of these colored dots is one of
those identifiers and so it plays okay
the video yeah okay are you scanning
through so you see all these projections
and going so we're moving we're moving
from the interior to the exterior yeah
just through the slice from the bottom
at the top for the bottom to right you
see all these colors yeah if we were to
iterate in a line or just take one slice
it would flash in the same way as that
other video flash and I'd be able to say
like oh this is so and i couldn't list
off the barcode yeah got it right okay
and this this right here that one dot I
can tell you what that is they are you
tell you what that sequences and then if
we find that another dot somewhere else
that same sequence
I know it's exact same cell
okay okay and then then your then your
your you're taking a three-dimensional
it's kind of like you're taking the
camera from the from the forget the base
of the brain and you're moving it out
towards the exterior of the brain and
this is what we're seeing pop up as the
kind of the neuronal structures that are
being shown and then the colors are
based on what cell what what the
sequence of the type of the cell is
based on however you see yeah so the
gray is just the the location for so and
what is white then whites yeah that's
where just where the cell boundary is
desoto so what was what was green and
the previous one is now white oh just a
free up color spaceman oh okay okay this
is a cell boundary yeah right so this is
like one large projection yeah right and
that's like the cell body
those are cell bodies oh our cell body
is oh no body and these are like the
long dendrites dinger can we take a
question from the audience yes Johann is
a molecular biologist and he wants to
know what is your intentions what are
your intentions of doing gene editing
did you answer that question already
your intentions Gina did but we don't
right now we're developing gene editing
technology right so we don't have the
projects currently aren't on the
applications of it we're trying to make
the technology better which is then
useful to everybody else doing any kind
of gene editing thank you we do have a
coating on recoding project again that
has to do with the fires resistance
right so if you can if you can basically
change all the codons in a Cell to
eliminate one of them a virus won't be
able to actually operate so you'd be
basically alter the genome so it can
still make all the proteins it wants to
but it's kind of handicap to make that
the ones you've removed and then and
then
so that would be an application that's
okay all right and then let's um let's
get let's get a little bit deeper into
this and then eventually what we want to
do is we want to be able to map the
entirety of brains right and then when
you do that then that gives you the
ability to what can we do with that so
you that gives you half the story okay
right so in biology especially in
neuroscience it's basically a form and
function right so you need anatomy you
need physiology so I'd have to know what
that neuron does right so and then I
would and then you need some sort of
behavior and to overlay with it so this
is actually the visual cortex this is
anatomy this is an atom so you're just
telling me what physically basically
they're plus not telling me anything
about how it functions you've all but
you have bar-coded and sequenced them
that's another thing so Anatomy plus bar
coding and sequencing right but the
sequencing is here to give the
connectivity in the anatomy yeah right
but there's no physiology there could be
we used to tell from the sequencing what
the physiology okay still from there
excitatory or inhibitory well we would
be able to we have ways to figure that
out okay but I don't know like the
firing rate in response to a visual
stimulus
oh okay so what you would do is you'd
have the mouse and you do do some sort
of behavior you know if you if you look
at the visual cortex to show it
something visual yeah right and then you
record the activity and then afterwards
you take the anatomy and then you
overlay okay so I will show images if
we're doing a a scan of the architecture
of the visual cortex I'd show an image
and then I would I would observe what
happens as I'm showing the image to see
what's happening physiologically right
and then you could do that over and over
again for the different areas of the
brain to understand the physiologies
that are occurring based on what stimuli
you're inputting yeah the neck isn't
then you're limited by technology for
physiology but we do have one of these
far out projects where we're trying to
write in physiology
into the cells how how you think that so
it's supposed to take this spike rate
and encode it on a stretch of DNA so
that we can read it later so if you do
that for potentially you would have the
whole brain encoding temporal
information that we read out at a later
time that's a little tricky yeah yeah
yeah and that's a spike rate and that
means like you'd have multiple spike
rates over time and that would certainly
overcome the ability to record from many
areas you'd be if you had a transgenic
Mouse that had that operating you would
know every every cell's operation within
that window so normally you would you
know the tool the two ways that people
are looking at physiology or the two
main ways the classic way we put an
electrode in and you just record right
and you could put in multiple electrodes
you can put electrode arrays but that's
still only really subsampling the brain
it's only a small fraction and what you
could also do is express a bunch of
proteins that that light up so when the
cell fires it did flashes I think put a
camera and watch it now you're limited
at that area of view where the cameras
implanted but if you could do this other
technique it's basically recording to
the whole thing all the time so you'd
slice it up into that information would
be written into the brain tissue and
then we do something like this to read
it out oh it gets written into the brain
tissue and then you read it out later
yeah
damn we're writing it into the brain
tissue what are the long-term effects of
that I mean it would it would be in a
mouse yeah and it would be for a you
know some designated period of time for
an experiment when it's one of our lofty
goals it's not is it's not as far along
as the anatomy yeah physiology is
there's a time component to physiology
that makes it a whole separate challenge
yeah they kind this is like the time
components of the physiology makes it
the private area
so this Anatomy this is like a one time
point in that mouse is for if you sack
the mouse and that's what the brain is
and now we're trying to analyze it yeah
yeah right okay so you need the anatomy
in the physiology to make the whole
connectome yeah yeah well it took at the
connectome the connectome is anatomy
it's just anatomy but it's more
important to also get the physiology
yeah yeah interesting and have we done a
connectome yet there yeah the the the
other technique this is sliced thin and
yeah and man is trying to scale up so
fruit fly brains things like that we did
get those yeah but uh and that's like a
fruit fly brain has what like most
options I mean it's in neurons or what
that should still be millions I mean but
it million so it's still I mean think of
a human brain the mouse brain is a
significant size reduction and a fly
brain is even smaller than there so it's
still a lot you can learn from from fly
brain right yes yeah I mean actually
there's a lot of conserved anatomy the
court the cortex the wrinkly party a
brain right that you see is it's kind of
crammed in there but it's really a flat
sheet and if you were to look at the
just a chunk of cortex and a human in
the mouse the monkey they're really hard
to tell the difference actually the
general anatomy is similar right yeah
the structure called a cortical column
that presumably has some general
algorithm that it processes information
with and it's just repeated across the
whole brains people are just trying to
kind of deconstruct the cortical column
so if you could do that in the visual
cortex of the mouse it should at least
something to say about like prefrontal
cortex in a human so said a general
feature of the brain with the cortex so
even that level of understanding still a
bit elusive in neuroscience and okay now
the brain initiative stuffs fastly I'm
super excited for you guys to keep
making moves there what about on the
stem cell therapy side of things all the
way to the reproductive technology side
of things I love this type of stuff I'm
something about something about stem
cell therapy gets me really excited
because it seems like it's one of the
big keys to longevity yeah so it's a
it's thus far kind of a smaller
component of the symbol platform but it
may be something that is emerging if
we're trying to put resources into it I
think I would be great if we can push
more stem cell research and we could do
more in terms of the reproductive
biotechnology too because that's kind of
an exciting area I know I've only
recently kind of cracked open this this
field and discovered this field of in
vitro gamma go Genesis so I'm not sure
if you've heard of this but you can take
a well you could take a human cell and D
differentiate into a stem embryonic stem
cell like cell called IPS cell that's
kind of old news that already won the
Nobel Prize that's being done all over
the place and the glory of that is
that's your own cell sort of your own
DNA so if you if you were to
differentiate into some cell for cell
therapy it wouldn't have any kind of
immune rejection but what's currently
not possible in humans is to make germ
cells out of that but a lot of work has
been able to do that in animals like
mice so it's probably gonna be possible
that sometime in the future you'd be
able to take your cell convert it to one
of these other cells and differentiate
it into a sperm cell so if you have
people that have fertility issues or
people that have injuries I know a lot
of
cancer treatments for kids actually
makes them infertile as a side effect so
these people grew up and they just
simply can't have any this would be a
way to kind of bypass your own
reproductive system to develop these
cells right so if that were to happen
then then somewhat of a cure for
infertility and can almost change like
the human dynamic of sexual reproduction
to some extent and I mean it's possible
that you wouldn't even I mean it open to
the possibility of like two people - two
men or two women to be able to have a
baby with their own genetic identity so
huge huge ramifications for a lot of
that stuff in terms of effect on society
how do we program all the dumb people to
stop having babies how do we do that
yeah that that's a different question I
don't know there there there are I think
it's a very very important topic though
it is a very important topic how do we
how do we maximize our collective
abilities on this rock yeah yeah and I
you know in terms of again in terms of
reproduction if you even if you could
just do Excel development right I mean a
lot of a lot of women freeze their eggs
and are unsuccessful it really I think
that a big immediate effect is on like
women's rights and women's abilities in
society but they're basically they the
biology is not is not even in terms of
its effect of reproduction with men and
women a lot of women feel this pressure
to have to have kids at an earlier age
because they feel like there's a clock
ticking mm-hm
if something like this could work it can
some somewhat eliminate that clock and
if that clock is eliminated that can
have a huge dynamic just in terms of
society that could be really beneficial
then we could wait until whatever time
we want to have children right yeah with
with the healthiest embryos as well yeah
that's great
yeah yep hmm part of that also that
question that that Ron's brought up it's
also interesting to think about what
reproductive technologies and genetic
engineering could do for all babies that
are being birthed into the world if
there if we do figure out longitudinally
what really good genetic edits are for
intelligence or working memory or or
metabolism that we could then there
would be the bar of intelligence just
keeps moving up yeah I think the
challenge is that when you look at human
traits like that it never falls into
like three genes that if they're active
this is your IQ it's not like a switch
that gets flipped
it's like these massively complex
combinations of genes that are not well
understood and you really get this
nurture nature component where it's
really difficult to parse out how much
of one happens versus the other it could
be that you get some statistical effect
that you can you can monitor saying like
oh people with
on average people with these mutations
or these genes or this much smarter and
then if you would do the edit it might
not actually end up that way because
this is less of a nature component than
you actually think it is it could be
better a better use of time to invest in
you know school system reform than gene
editing reform right as long as they
educate people on being critical
thinkers and not obedient workers talk
to them about enhancing their
intelligence not having them learn and
to repeat to program them to be creative
innovative find a better way for all of
us
sure yeah I mean I've always been
interested in the nurture nature debate
as far as I can remember and it's still
an open-ended question in terms of like
for specific instance how much of it one
versus the other
it's almost always both and in a
possible combination to kind of entangle
this is this is this is a critical point
is that when you have this potential of
the seed of a child that is trying to
unleash itself fully into the world if
they get squashed by the economic
political and social machinery and
inhibits its full creative expression
versus if you if it gets all the tools
that it needs if it gets all its basic
needs met and that if it's able to fully
creatively express itself so then our
one of our goals with the show is to
constantly be propagating conversation
around the world in action around the
world around how to make a better social
fabric that enables that full creative
expression for every seed because then
you don't get the the instances where
it's just gets squashed by the system
other thoughts around quick on stem
cells I really think that there's just
so much potential that people have been
saying now around stem cells for
longevity purposes yeah yeah I mean
aging is another thing no that obviously
is interest interesting to us and a lot
of people it's very hard thing to tackle
because it's such a diffuse thing right
it's just a you know it's almost tough
to even define what aging is and how
look at it because it's it's basically
what's happening all the time to
everything in your body the loss of
homeostatic capacity yeah so how do you
how do you have a treatment or a cure
that that can like attack all these
things or fix all these things or change
all these things really difficult so
there are a lot of experiments that I've
seen or you take like the young blood of
a mouse and put it through an older pair
of biosis yeah you can actually take two
mice and surgically connect them in such
a way that their circulatory systems are
fused and you kind of average out the
the phenotype right the older Mouse gets
better and the younger Mouse gets older
so to speak so you just take the young
leader of blood or from the young and
give it to the old and that way they
regenerate the blood
the young doesn't yeah yeah so
presumably you can measure in a cell
therapy that that creates a mimic of the
young blood and then you can infuse that
presumably that would that would have an
anti-aging effect and there are also
very powerful cells in the bone marrow
yeah that's where a lot of the the
blood-borne stem cells are yeah and so
then to be able to extract that in a
safe way and then deliver that to people
along there aging as well there's all
different types of ways that this
potentially the growth of the stem cells
as well in its own Matt bioreactors and
then yeah yeah yeah there's all these
these effects of aging like a you know
your your genome is mostly fixed right
your DNA is not supposed to change but
when it replicates it does so it
accumulates errors and there's also the
epigenetics like the way it's read
changes because you get these marks on
it that accumulate over time so one
theory is that a lot of the aging is as
epigenetic noise that builds up like
things everything SSL's differentiate
form tissues you get use these
epigenetic markers that kind of get
diffused over time and so if you could
just sort of rewrite those you can
install aging and that's totally
different mechanism than blood stuff so
you might have to have like
six or seven different therapy is going
in parallel to really kind of win the
war yeah yeah yeah this is a cool point
too is being able to merge the different
therapies together yeah yeah oh just
retaining the 15 year olds homeostatic
capacity throughout life and being able
to experience more travel more create
more or have more relationships yeah
spend more time with the people that we
love watch how civilization flourishes
there's so many components to the
longevity better half I think none of us
live that's really deserved to live
beyond 30 so anyway at this that's just
my opinion
I should have been dead a long time ago
and there's so many other thoughts
around the work that can be done with
synthetic biology that we didn't hit the
extinct species resurrection yeah like
how important that is to have a deeper
sense of awe for what has happened on
the plan in the past and organ
engineering the these types of things so
there's still a bunch of other topics
and synthetic but I mean if you think
about the you know the reproductive
biotechnology which you know I was
discussing with respect to human
fertility presumably that could help
with the extinct species as well you
know if you have if you have the genome
and you understand at least enough of
the reproduction you might be able to
recapitulate that and bring back species
yeah that's that's not that's far out
from what's being done but you know who
knows possibility yeah I'm for sure
ready to have like a mini t-rex you know
just hanging out around the studio that
is like playful that like you know just
in muscles you know you will get over it
it's gone for a reason and when we're
extinct I hope they just leave it at
that yeah let's go home yeah I think
think about all the cool yeah all that
could be expand pond and like you said
with reproductive technology especially
as well as like what can we do to be
able to give people back power to to
eradicate disease there's so many cool
things to do there augmentation like you
said is really challenging it's like a
hard to figure out exactly where that's
at okay let's let's ask a couple
questions on the way out that we like
asking the people that we feature on the
show so
to see what you think do you think we're
alone in the cosmos I you know I'm the
kind of person who doesn't doesn't
speculate as much as if there's no data
I don't I tend to not wonder as much
it's big place it seems likely but I do
I like believe it or do I know it I
think a certain thing is almost like an
irrelevant question unless there's some
indication one way or the other
so unless unless we find it unless it's
there then we'll just we just don't know
it's sort you talk no do you think we're
in a simulation I don't I mean it
doesn't feel like it but that is almost
meaningless you know that that's kind of
it's almost like a circular question
because if it's so compelling of a
simulation that you can't tell it's a
simulation then you wouldn't be able to
know if you're in a simulation not
simulations so it's almost like what's
the point of it is a simulation don't
see it yeah so I mean it doesn't I don't
think there's any reason to think that
we are but it would have to be pretty
compelling simulation there's theories
of consciousness that say it's all an
illusion right and so I always have kind
of a similar take on that like well if
it's an illusion then there's such it's
so compelling that we believe the
illusion then is it make a difference if
it's an illusion or not you know then
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world beautiful thing in
the world
well I can have I guess two answers to
that I would say I still think the
ability of a piece of matter to operate
in such a way that it becomes self-aware
is pretty amazing so that's maybe an
objective scientific one but I think I
can go more corny on a personal level
and I could probably say my my kids
mm-hmm I just had kids ten months ago
ten months ago so I can go I can
definitely go with that one going into
this exponential technology age I'm
curious and the geopolitical craziness
also that we're entering with it what we
say is an important skill for kids to
know and including even your you know
ten month old and whatnot I think it's
about it's definitely on how how to get
to the truth I don't know why something
is real or not how do we evaluate
information and make a important
judgment on that instead of just
memorizing things and just like
regurgitating facts the ability to know
why you know something at least defend
it you know so if somebody says
something you say well why do you
believe that to actually have an answer
because it seems like nowadays it
doesn't even get to that there's not
that much there's not that wonder of
self analysing right and I mean that
goes hand-in-hand science that's just
that it that's kind of what science is
there's an experimental component to it
but it's kind of teaching you how to
think yeah so it'd be great if everybody
did you know engage more in the sciences
and but or even philosophy but that
seems like a hard angle to push for the
majority of people because there hasn't
been a big influx in that direction I'm
not sure what would take it to take that
to to change that in the future but
definitely you know critical thinking
skills yeah yeah and yeah and there's
that that's huge so that's well said
about what we need for the future
Ritchie this has been a really strong
episode I really appreciate you coming
on and teaching us about synthetic cloud
thanks for having me huge thank you for
coming on the show you shout out to
round Vargas for producing and directing
thank you very much we greatly
appreciate it Ronnie and I'd love for
everyone that watched give us your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode let us know what you're thinking
on it go and talk more conversations
about synthetic biology with your
friends your families your co-workers
people online on social media get
talking about it check out the links
below to Ritchie Coleman calm as well as
his Visa Institute profile page linked
in Google Scholar pace check out those
links everyone and also support the
artists entrepreneurs the organizations
around the world that you believe in
your community support simulation our
links are below help us grow in scale
and go and build build the future
execute your dreams into reality we love
you so much thank you for tuning in and
we will see you soon peace
[Music]